oh my gosh it's the craziest place in
Seattle that was just a start
and I got this cheese is so good it's so
lovely and you just set the bar really
hot I'm in Seattle and I'm so so excited
to be here I'm meeting up with my friend
Linda also known as salty Seattle she
makes the most gorgeous pastas and she
knows all the best places to go and
she's gonna show me how to eat like a
Seattle local let's go meet her
[Music]
Alexa ah it's so good to see you we
always eat so much when we're together
favourite type of friend so we're in
Pike Place Market a part of Pike Place
Market is features cheese that's where
I'm gonna take you first best way to
start today let's do it
my name is John Goucher I work at
Beecher's handmade cheese we're based in
Seattle down in the Pike Place Market we
have an urban cheese-making facility at
Beecher's we bring in local milk from
two very high quality farms and we
produce that milk in two very high
quality cheese all of our cheeses are
based on our primary brand which is
flagship an aged sort of a Gouda cheddar
combination lot of depth of flavor well
what's really unique about Beacher's is
you can get the best mac and cheese on
earth and watch the cheese that's in it
being produced that end product is just
excellent
so the basic process is pasteurize the
milk add the carefully selected starter
cultures to the milk and when the vats
full we set it and then we pump the
curds in way over to another VAT that we
use to drain the whey off and then we
start a traditional chattering process
then we run it through a mill to mill it
into curds again so that we can then
form it into blocks after the cheese is
aged 14 months or longer it is converted
into the triangle shape that you see
[Music]
okay Cheers you think oh my god this
cheese are so good and it's rich and
insulting except it's like moderate
toast it's so perfect
it's everything that is right in the
world sandwiched between two pieces of
delicious bread this mac and cheese how
creamy it is I want to actually talk to
myself into a blanket warmly well of
myself in the days like we could dive
into that battle of slowly Washington
cheese it's a thing it's incredible if
you're coming here you've got to go to
beaches I thank you really well because
I think our next thing we just need to
have a nice solid base to get through I
have no idea what to expect to be honest
that's getting pretty very afraid you
can see that I brought you to probably
the craziest place in Seattle our
tourist attraction called the gum wall
it actually has been here since the
early 90s there used to be a concert
venue nearby and before they went into
the concert people would take their gum
out and stick it onto the wall and
initially they would also stick pennies
and things onto the gum but that kind of
fell out unlike the initial story like
that has some charm and like rudiness
early 90s ya know they tried to clean it
off completely in 2015 it took over a
week to do what we're looking at this is
just the last three years of
accumulation that is so upsetting it's
kind of like wax it feels like it's
gonna be like sticky we got to
contribute woman right yeah stick it on
yep right by the bumblebee oh you can
come down here and spend hours and sort
of do like gum graffiti art and people
do I would call this like the opposite
not tasty I think we need a cleanse
shall we so we're here at Cafe Hitchcock
I am chef Brendan McGill and we are here
downtown Seattle Cafe Hitchcock we're
down here in the central business
district people come in for a quick bite
we want to make it about twice as good
as
but they expect so we're bringing local
farm food independent restaurant craft
we try to source things as carefully as
possible and we cured and smoked all of
our own meats today we're gonna make a
rice bowl as well as our chicken club
sandwich really delicious but sort of
guilt-free I'm gonna make our chicken
club sandwich so we use a potato roll
and this is a Green Goddess aioli and
then it's gonna get some bacon jam this
chicken breast we brine all our chicken
breasts and lettuce and tomato we're
gonna make a rice bowl this is a basil
pesto to the bowl this is a soft-boiled
egg so I should have a runny yoga when
you break into it it's gonna dress your
rice bowl even more purple cabbage slaw
roasted carrots this is our kimchi
tumeric pickled cauliflower a little bit
of raw kale to mixin pickled hair
Colbert and Fresno's
[Music]
we like to have fun we want you to come
in here and have fun too the concept
here is a little bit more vibrant as you
can see from our drinks we've got it I'm
gonna claw teh what is this so this is a
loose karolina it's a superfood there's
a little bit of a pick-me-up post cheese
pick-me-up sounds it's in Seattle you
know we really like just balance our
indulgences Wow
oh my goodness so you can see it's
really colorful and beautiful but it's
also it's gonna fill up up I think I'm
gonna just go straight up in that
perfect you there's like a hint of smoke
in here and then delicious a la that I
want it actually just like tradesies it
just feels so fresh and vibrant this is
so good let's try some of these drinks
Cheers
smooth it tastes a bit like kombucha
this is so nice to see a real local
favorite so now that we feel so vibrant
and refreshed and colorful I'm going to
take you on another really cool colorful
adventure before dinner you're gonna be
so excited that we made dance or skip I
can't wait let's do it
we're under an umbrella because it was
now raining it was so beautiful earlier
what happened this is a Seattle I know
[Music]
I'm particularly excited because Waze
was just nominated as one of the 50 best
restaurants in the country this is gonna
be a gastronomic
aventure my name is Hawara
I'm ownership of was Keisuke restaurant
heisuke is Japanese fine dining
I'm from Kyoto so I'm trying to read
Java style high-tech within named shadow
I wanted to introduce more wider variety
of Japanese food every month I try to
create a new menu with Kyoto style
traditional cooking method with local
seasonal ingredients actual style
cuisine sometimes it's very old style
and I'm trying to transform for more
modern style that's my style
here a song we are so excited we are
excited and way so much for having us
yeah that's the good Sukkot
yes yeah Wow fresh like glass of water
really I could get to the bottom of that
dangerously so poor dishes today
they're hustling I like a a so tomato
appetizer we put five food in one plate
king crab tacos sushi and sushi rice
rest in wooden box it's like you're
making us a little gift
Wow and it's beautiful Wow the next one
is definitely our mixed with cucumber
and CEO raised the duck breast with
mustard miso vinegar scalp Siad outside
subdivers honey the [ __ ] cured was
cozy oh she is committed rice last one
is it's a lot of purity oh my gosh I'm
scallop sandwich a mince caliber
I need a minute I need like a private I
need all men with justice is there a
room that
we could go into the scallop is so fresh
and it's sweet it looks so simple but
the nuances of flavor in that one come
on the depth to it
okay I'm going to the doctor oh it's so
smoky Wow
all of this feel is subtly sweet
but crunch from the cucumbers is so nice
you have to use really exceptional
ingredients to do that you should be
proud and the next course is sashimi
today gonna be local albacore tuna live
spot prawn my sashimi dish is assortment
of local fish and Japanese fish from
Japan now we really are gonna cry in
school
Wow I'm going prom I'm gonna handhold I
mean it is legitimately the freshest
from I've ever had it tastes like the
ocean it's crisp and firm but it melts
at the entire about that is like the
waves coming over you I'm gonna go for
the tuna now all of this fish may be
fresher than the fish I had in Japan
which is great sinking I'm gonna say a
little prayer for how beautiful that is
every flavor is so clean
there's no pretentiousness it's
presented simply beautifully it simply
Mexico solution Oggy
sushi host is Wagyu beef from the Japan
and the grade is a five I sliced and
like please here originally high taking
not already have lead posts but in here
the people really like me let's try from
your left side the one is just salt and
wasabi the other one was on the sauce a
grated daikon radish and putting the
whole thing in my mouth like right now I
have to just go for it
mmm it just sings on its own and to do
anything more to it really with these
yeah the buns you've swapped the
spiciness for a little bit of sweetness
this is the highest grade trees on the
planet and you can taste it meat in
general is not something that I included
my diet all the time and so when I eat
it I want to eat it as freshly and
really as perfectly as possible in this
Victoria chemo and today see a kimono is
local coho salmon from Olympic Peninsula
and mixed with yuzu Kosho sauce the
grilled peach looks like a potato
I thought they were potatoes donut
peaches some customer and confused when
they tried food and it's very sweet
I'm trying to keep it together but this
meal is a transcendental experience
really so you would say a little bit of
donut peach with salmon at the same time
I've never
the salmon is cooked perfectly it feels
like a palate cleanser really these
articles caramel ice cream we made ice
cream in the house and the seasonal
movie how the world's fresh will green
tea matcha it's like a Japanese style
wahoo Adam I love the careful plating of
everything it's a cool and creamy
instead of like the caramel the adzuki
adds like a double caramel to it really
feels like hers with care and thought
into every single ingredient and
preparation that goes into this now that
we're at the end from the very first
thing I put into my mouth there's
thought to the sequence I think what's
so special about this meal is like
everything feels so intentionally here a
solid you made magic of this evening for
us and for that word for it to be
I had so many awesome experiences to
choose from in Seattle and now I get to
choose how to pay for them with peut
planet from American Express
Seattle's magical but I think part of
that is just getting to share that
experience with friends it makes Seattle
special I truly can't thank you enough
so next time
[Music]
you